people may think the lesson in this
movie is don't sell drugs don't smuggle
drugs because bad [ __ ] happens but it's
not the lesson in this movie is nearly
20 years after friends started airing
Jennifer Aniston is still hot that is
what I took away from this
we're the Millers sentence form best way
to do a title so we're the Millers stars
that one dude who's really funny and in
real life the guys actually nailing
Olivia Wilde so as I like to call him
[ __ ]
forget for him really Bane stands and he
goes around town and he sells pot
apparently he's really good at it but
then he loses his entire stash and all
of his money to the cast of the movie
Lost Boys so Ed Helms his boss is like
yeah you're gonna go down to Mexico get
a little bit of weed and bring it back
to America a little friend upon in some
circles but you're gonna do it and in
order to accomplish this he gets these
misfits together to pose as a family he
gets Jennifer Aniston who plays a
stripper in this movie to pose as his
wife he gets Emma Roberts who's this
young runaway check she poses as his
daughter and then he gets the kid who
played the brat in the Narnia movies to
pose as his son they dress up as beaver
cleaver Vil family who shops with the
gap outlet and then they go across the
border and they get the weed and they
come back and then shenanigans ensue
you're like okay that's kind of this a
funny premise thing is that is a really
entertaining 45-minute long movie in the
middle though you have to fill in the
gaps and draw it out to be about an hour
45 minutes long in which you have a
bunch of just other things in there
there's this whole segment with this
weird other camper family and I saw the
segment in the trailer and I was like
okay it's gonna be just in passing but
it felt like that segment dragged on in
this movie I felt like it was like 33
percent of the entire movie one-third of
this movie was dedicated to this
weird-ass family that they just gonna
run across and then hang out with new
weird comedy with the movie does have a
good heart felt prime-minister about you
know what is family and these misfits
kind of find a family within themselves
but it's a really predictable movie you
don't walk away from this movie gun I
didn't see any of that coming it's cool
to see this dude in a lead role because
I was like can he be a lead role not
like I have to root for him in life a
guy's obviously really good at what he
does he's really funny he made me laugh
a lot in this movie and he actually gets
Olivia Wilde in real life it's not like
he's the underdog anymore but I like
seeing the dude succeed and bear with me
on this I know the whole point of this
movie is that other bonding as a family
but really the whole family thing was
there all camouflage to pose as a family
so they can get back to America through
the Mexican border
you know they blend anslee alright
modern American family whatever go past
so once they're in the USA again they
really don't have to stick together
theirs is one
segment in the movie I'm not going to
spoil it for you so don't worry but
someone is more or less incapacitated
and they need to get him into the RV so
they can just go about their quest but
they're already in America so if I were
him I'd be like all right you guys stay
with him I'm gonna go back and drop the
drugs off soon so you know it's a time
limit thing then I'll come back and get
ya after he's okay and we'll all be fine
but no he doesn't think of that he's
like oh we got to stick together but I
don't like any of you so I don't really
want to stick together with you guys
it's kind of a conflicting message thing
I was like all right so it's just
convenience they have to stick together
because we wouldn't have a movie
otherwise stuff like that pulls me out
of the movie makes me go oh well if it
doesn't make sense my brain doesn't like
it we're the Millers made me laugh I
thoroughly enjoyed like half of this
movie I really felt like I said they had
a 45-minute long movie that was really
funny but they had to stretch it out to
make it long enough to be in theaters
and so now she's not as solid as it
would have been there's a part of me
that wants to give a subtext here so I
just might I'll say we're the Millers is
a good time no alcohol required at
matinee price all right so this movies
about smuggling weed what's your
favorite drugs smuggling movie comedy
drama whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you